welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and one division spent the holiday
dropping promos faster than fruit
clothesline by wanda's baby bump there's
a ton of new footage to break down from
several promos since our last trailer
breakdown with visual clues and easter
eggs that are
easy to overlook yes it's a new year and
i am now
in an even smaller blue dungeon a true
pocket reality mind prison to keep me
focused on churning out videos faster
but with anybody living space
kind of like a dog kennel if i make a
mess i gotta sleep in it
because if darla can be housebroken so
can
i oh she spoke too soon so let's break
it all down starting with the latest
trailer the one that dropped january 4th
titled
new era this trailer features a nifty
sitcom theme song
oh this is gonna be a gap
this was composed by kristin anderson
lopez and robert lopez the songwriting
duo behind frozen
coco the book of mormon and avenue q
apparently they've composed unique
sitcom theme songs for every decade the
show's gonna feature so we can probably
expect one in the style of jesse
fredrik's late 80s run to the abc
sitcoms
that workhorse did full house family
matters step by step and perfect
strangers i love the jump cut as vision
and wanda's wedding rings flip onto
their fingers
the edit is a bit sloppy and janky the
way productions used to have their
actors freeze as they reset between
takes as we saw in bewitched and i dream
of genie it's
charmin charm later shots and colors
show that wanda's center stone here is
red a ruby
reflecting her as the scarlet witch
wanda finds a
toy helicopter in technicolor a shot
similar to something we'd see in
pleasantville it is numbered
3003 which is too close for i love you
3000 for me to just ignore
but this thing has a sword logo on the
front
whoa so at first i thought this was just
like a remote toy from the outside that
accidentally skewed into the pocket
reality to give wanda a clue that this
is all bs kind of like truman finding
that crash stage light
instead i am now thinking this is that
full-size helicopter
that glides past the red staticky pocket
reality wall in the other footage
but then gets absorbed by the pocket
reality and transformed into this
toy that might explain how sword agent
monica rambo
ends up as a sitcom supporting role
maybe every agent sword sent in there
gets assimilated into wanda's sitcom
reality
every vehicle or weapon transformed into
something harmless
the way the reality stone warped drax
into blocks in infinity war wanda
envisioned perform a magic act in a
talent show in front of wentworth's
department store
maybe a nod to deidre wentworth superior
from cap's battle with the famazons
later head of hammer
or just the name of a local department
store the store behind wanda is just
mops so i'm not sure how much thought
was put into these storefronts
agnes leads a standing ovation followed
by this guy
juan envisioned seemed confused by the
reaction as if they maybe really didn't
earn
this win maybe they screwed up their
magic trick but this mindless crowd
praises them anyway because the script
says that they win the front table shows
this woman in a donkey costume
probably another act looking like well
they beat me there and square and i have
no bitterness whatsoever
the guy with the mustache sitting with
her appears behind wanda in some other
footage of her in modern clothes so i'm
guessing
all of these town residents flash
forward with wanda envisioned through
the decades
now on to the beekeeper we saw this guy
in the december trailer now
he is climbing out of the sewer bees
swarming around him the back of his suit
has another sword logo we could be
looking at another pocket reality
transformation like the sword agent is
in some kind of protective jumpsuit but
then
the reality warped that suit from the
outside to something like that of a
beekeeper but you can somewhat more
clearly make out this guy's face
especially if you brighten the shot but
from what i could tell this isn't anyone
else we know to be in the cast at this
point
wanda envisions tandem bike ride takes
him past adler's fresh
produce and seafood oh another name
another possible match to marvel comics
where pretty much every name already
exists
irene adler aka destiny a
mutant precognitive who can accurately
predict future events and wipe in
partner to mystique i don't know folks
maybe this
bubble reality warps all of reality
within it so that mutants
exist there and then when that bubble
bursts mutants will exist all over the
mcu now the movie theater behind them is
playing
oz the great and powerful which is a
weird anachronism for the live-action
disney movie that came out in 2013
whereas this reality seems to be set in
the 70s
though that movie was directed by sam
raimi director
of doctor strange and multiverse of
madness which wanda maximoff is
confirmed to come back
in speculated to be the villain also oz
the great and powerful is a story about
a magician trying to sort
out a good witch from a bad witch a
motif that seems to be continuing with
vision in his
magic act and the good and bad witches
of wandavision
wanda and agnes they waved to monica
rambo sitting outside
m and b hardware maybe b is a person
m monica runs the store with ooh but
before i continue a quick word about the
really big news from our merch store the
epic hero shop
we had a lot of fun with our first shirt
in the latest obsession line with our
mandalorian inspired this is the way
shirt the limited run of that shirt
sold out and that design is now locked
up in the blue dungeon for all of
eternity
but we have two new one division
inspired designs that we are super
excited about
these shirts are unlike anything we've
done before and really unlike any shirt
i've ever seen
i mean it these shirts are the next
level bonkers cool just like the disney
plus series inspiring them we will be
revealing the designs this friday in our
first episode of the inside marvel one
division after show
also really quick we wanted to let you
know yes our merch is always available
at new rockstarsmerch.com but that's in
partnership
with our epic hero shop and we've
actually got
very cool news from epic hero shop
itself that you're gonna want to listen
to
those people that already clicked ahead
you're gonna regret missing this well
for everyone who stayed i want you to
know that epic hero shop
just launched a new mysterious maybe
nerdy maybe
funny maybe who knows youtube channel
and is celebrating that with some
giveaways
of what oh how about just a little thing
called
a sony playstation 5 disc edition
because we know we're all gonna try out
our scratched up rayman discs and that
beast and see what happens
i'm pretty sure it's rayman reaching out
and slapping you with this creepy
dismembered hand but
uh back to that giveaway as epic hero
shop launches this new channel called
epic hero labs they'll be doing multiple
giveaways of not one not
two but eventually 10 ps5s
to honor the road to 100 000 subscribers
and it starts right now you can go to
epic hero shop.com
giveaway or click the link in the
description to enter and you'll see
all the details there but basically
following the various epic hero accounts
gives you
entries it's that simple again full
details at the link in the description
epic hero shop.com giveaway and we will
be publicly announcing the first
giveaway winner after
the epic hero labs youtube channel hits
10 000 subscribers so if you are over 18
and in the us or canada go get to
entering i'll be here waiting
next a close-up shows wanda's twin
babies in the crib
presumably these are wiccan in speed
notice how one of them has a red mark on
his forehead
maybe it's a birthmark from vision's
mind stone or maybe it's just the weird
pink marks that
show up on babies and then disappear
when they turn into humans don't tell me
babies are humans they're just
little flesh potatoes that start talking
at some point agnes greets them in the
80s set
other footage shows how this whole
confusion will cause agnes to kind of
reset as if doing a second take
in the middle of a tv show yeah that's a
bad take why don't i um
take that from the top as of doing a
second take in the middle of a
tv show production
[Applause]
behind vision are these bird paintings
we in the past have determined these to
be a variegated fairy wren
and a phoenix chicken which both might
be clues reflecting the caged birds of
wanda
in vision in this pocket reality vision
if you can see him as the phoenix
resurrecting
once again there's the shadowy outline
in the pocket reality
static border and then a shot of their
modern looking home
warping again their tv switches from
this modern morning talk show to what
looks like a old-timey sitcom
and look at that they got a nintendo wii
they know how to have fun
now some new details from the other
promos that i gotta point out
the january third signal promo gives a
shot of the clock radio that jimmy wu
tries to communicate them with
i find it interesting that there's no
six on this clock face like there's a
six on the radio dial but
not on the clock maybe it's just a clock
design thing you know sometimes they
leave numbers off clocks or
maybe it's the secret to everything and
there are already two sixes and if you
were to have a third six
mephisto would get beetlejuice into the
room
now in the january first visionary new
era promo we do see this clock radio
short circuit and then like reverse to
normal so clearly this thing is going to
break when it's used this way
or if someone tries to prevent jimmy woo
from contacting wanda and then there's a
shot of agnes reading from that same
glamorous magazine brand but a much
earlier edition
inside there is a special report that
mentions a
husband and then on christmas there is a
reality promo where
vision uses his super speed to catch a
falling piece of fruit maybe setting up
how one of their kids will be a
speedster a close-up of monica rambo
shows her looking in confusion down at
her
necklace which appears to contain an
upside down
cross so metal while some associate this
with a satanic
meaning and christianity and upside down
cross is the symbol of saint peter who
insisted on being crucified upside down
there's also more of the flashback to
wanda's pre-avengers years at the hydra
base in sokovia which i believe could
lead to a pietro maximoff quick silver
cameo since he was there at that time
wanda's warping wall also depicts that
same hydra base from age of ultron here
she
sees the mind stone when it's still in
its blue casing as it was in loki's
scepter maybe we'll get some answers to
that because otherwise it was really
just oh marvel didn't know the scepter
would contain an infinity stone and they
had already made it blue and they
already had a blue one with the space
stone and they just had to like pluck it
out and make it yellow so it's a
minestrone now and then bathrobe wanda
wearing her modern looks staring
directly into camera making me think
this era might be based on modern family
when characters do direct to camera
talking head confessionals a gimmick
that they took from the office but
it kind of makes zero sense in modern
family because like who is doing that
documentary
i cannot wait to dig more into the show
all the easter eggs all the methysto
theories we are going to be doing our
inside marvel one division after show
same day
every friday for the next couple of
months and as always my easter egg
breakdowns coming out
the next day on saturday and again you
can support new rockstars by checking
out our many
great merch options at
newrockstarsmerge.com follow me on
instagram at eavos follow new rockstars
subscribe to new rockstars here on
youtube for analysis and coverage of all
the big stuff you missed
thanks for watching boom
[Music]
you